[Music]
[Applause]
mayday mayday this is the sawer 2 we're
under attack by P requesting immediate
aid they say everybody's good at
something me I talked to Fish that's how
I met my friend
storm he's always there when I need to
[Music]
lift some people think that makes me a
joke but I don't care you know why cuz
I'm also good at something
else and that's breaking
heads Papa cck on all the Pirates I was
like what
Pirates
those Chum lickers didn't stand a
chance I'll k your asses and took their
[Music]
names sorry pops my bad oh yeah this is
my son Arthur junr you see 4 years ago
everything changed I met a woman I fell
in love the next thing I know we're
getting married and having a kid this
little guy is the best thing that ever
happened to
me this kid he doesn't
[Music]
sleep and he never
misses and then I'm up with the crack of
dawn because on top of getting married
and having a kid I finally got a
job that's right I'm the king of
freaking Atlantis B to
be can I score that you asked well I
stopped my brother war from attacking
the surface world and in doing so I
claimed the throne from
him at first I was
like the territorial waters are but then
as it turned out being King wasn't all
it's cracked up to
being it's just meetings all day and
politics
I'm so bored I don't even know which end
of the Brian King I'm supposed to be
looking at half the
time W yeah that was awesome and if
that's not bad enough turns out there's
this whole Council of houses thing that
nobody told me about which basically
gets to shoot down everything I want to
do the only thing that makes all the
hard work and sleepless nights
worthwhile is hanging with my little
man
miss of course there are fun parts of
the
job I get to keep the sea safe the best
way I know
out especially when I get to take down
the legal cage fight or
[Applause]
two but for everything I get right
something else gets screwed
up
[Music]
To Be
Wild
oh yeah here you
go
launcher
so he's going to need a little brother
or sister to play
with he's got a
dog hey I'm
serious saw how lonely it was for you
growing up an only
child I always regretted I couldn't give
you
that yeah well don't be too hard on
yourself turns out I have a brother and
he's a total dick bag come on your
relationship with
M isn't how it usually is Che siblings
bicker and
fight but at the end of the day they're
family you should be able to count on
them for help
yeah well I'll still take the dog over
him any
day hey look at
that holy
crap
hi baby boy are you talking to the
[Music]
fishies oh man pops is blowing in my
mind my whole life I've wanted to share
this gift with someone yeah you and me
son are
different
special we're connected to the land and
the sea I can't wait to introduce you to
all the majestic creatures on our planet
and show you how awesome this will can
be yeah you and
[Music]
me
the crust reference the the coordinates
from Dr Shen nothing still no sign of
atlan in remnants under the ice looks
like he's led us on another wild goose
chase every day I don't fix my power
suit is another day Aquaman gets to
live check
again we're close this time I can feel
it Expedition log day
463 Dr Steven Shin recording my quest
for Atlantis has brought me to the ends
of the Earth David Kane is losing his
patience if I don't turn up the Atlantic
technology he's looking for soon they're
probably going
to
um you know what let's not even go there
I'm sure everything will be
fine Dr Shin take a look at this please
tell me you found something seismic R is
going crazy where's the EP
Center we're standing
[Music]
on
run